[Music]
check out ugly Christmas sweater dot-com
slash beauty plan and you as well can
look this great yeah
order now before Christmas and it will
arrive in time for Christmas who said I
don't have the hardest merch in the game
who dare question my merch game are the
Christmas cards that calm safe feedback
now we have a bit of a problem we can no
longer make fun t-series is open but you
know Indian people Facebook is how this
whole thing started the whole bobs
invokana but who am I possibly going to
make fun of now for being bad at
internet for being bad at writing post
on Facebook that's right
old people I don't know how this has
never been flag to me before but old
people Facebook it's a goddamn gold mine
I'm sorry India but old people take the
prizes we have such golden posts on
Facebook as it's with great sadness in
my heart that I can't even read this why
would you see I don't know I haven't
used Facebook in so long I don't know
what these are I guess it's like a
template to make a text pose more
interesting you can pick a background
and for some reason they pick them
crying laughing emoji background thank
you Mark Zuckerberg very cool I just
made me set genuinely sad I am old
school I do not use a cell phone I do
not have caller ID I am gay what an a
fantastic profile picture I can it's
like no I'm not bald look there's hair
up there luck oh I love this one my
friends grandma went to get passport
photos about 10 years ago but didn't
quite understand the photo poof and
ended up with this Jam so cute I can
only imagine she's sitting there hoping
to get a passport photo and this thing
prints you can still use it as a
passport photo I'm pretty sure Justin
please add me here thank you
I don't care about
it's gay come on Justin what are you
doing add your grandmother Facebook this
makes me really glad that I don't have
Facebook anymore
here's a perfect example of what Mark
Zuckerberg meant when he wanted to
connect people we have one person
posting mum passed away last night
rest in peace my lovely mom signs of
symptoms of irritable bowel syndrome you
know this happened because if you post a
hyperlink in your Facebook post and then
delete it it still posed the whole thing
as an image link so she had just this
article copied in her control and pasted
probably oh my god
but my favorite of this post is the
comment oat milk you know in some
cultures old milk is a sign of grief I
don't know what is this
it's just what parents are doing on
Facebook now that they've taken over
this social media maybe we're the ones
that use Facebook wrong all along
sending prayers
I'm so sorry about the heartbreak Debbie
the absolute savage law that's not
what's supposed to come up there but I
pray for you and hugs through the whole
family then delete it Debbie
you know exactly what you're doing
Debbie don't even pretend goddamn can I
say
I'd look goddamn good our next post
comes from another Facebook this
probably could be the greatest chain of
posts of all time Andrea I'm glad what
she'll be fine she'll be okay she'll be
okay she's okay
prayers for her praise for her prayers
prayers prayers prayers prayers hassle
okay prayers hassle okay hassle hungry
why can't I boss god bless you Andrea
god bless you and thank you for your
prayers Wow just saw for Hugh coyotes on
the railroad
I'm so good via host oh this one is
great Tara I didn't know this but
apparently still some young people use
Facebook for whatever reason posting
stuff like this Tara I hate Rihanna now
apparently her grandma saw this post and
she commented she might be mean to you
Tara but that doesn't mean you have to
be mean to her
that's right Geraldine you've got Tim
right there's no reason to be mean to
Rihanna just like there's no reason to
be mean to me okay because I'm not mean
to you you dummy here's a review on an
Amazon for HP 63 black and tricolor
original ink cartridges the service was
great it was delivered fast and just
what I need is he an ink cartridge
perhaps my homeowners insurance company
posted a video about water damage reply
where is the information needed to find
my you gotta go you gotta wait for this
one needed to find my way main water Wow
I bought this house used instead of
newly built and finding anything has
been difficult
the former owner lives down the street
but always says I don't know when I
inquire about something what is this
how did I get to YouTube don't waste my
time with this not Judy
that's right YouTube stop wasting Judith
time with such nonsense
are you kidding me over here YouTube
always wasting my time I hate it I
wouldn't promote two mergers in one
video
you got damn wrong baby the Pew news
hats are selling like a goddamn God God
it's selling whatever shut up these will
only be available for one more date so
now it's your last chance to check out
represent calm / beautify I'm just
saying it because life's chance and I'm
really happy with his margin I think
it's really cool okay there's a very
slick 70 million Club
lasagna merch hmm looks so good an edgy
pew news much Oh lalala
designed by PewDiePie and of course the
sukkah lasagna hoodie very nice ok
granny message to wish me luck on my
test all the best for today I will be
thinking of you
lots of granny x-x-x ChatterBait granny
don't you just love it when you're
blessed with granny sex for good fortune
on your test someone posted to the
public Facebook group of Walmart saying
my grandson is supposed to be having a
job interview is he there hi Phyllis we
hope your grandson did well Walmart
replies Phyllis replaced he didn't go he
was busy catching those poked bugs on
his phone very upset with him with poke
bugs does he mean Pokemon I would pick I
would probably pick playing Pokemon over
a ball might an interview so this is
from a group where a foldable Bluetooth
keyboard is for sale for $20 and someone
asks is this item still available yep
just got your message does it work
yep I just no longer have a practical
use for it is it loud this is all
reasonable questions by the way no it's
a membrane board oh never mind
you want a loud keyboard why you have
one and how much all I have is 20 is it
bluetooth yet it's a Bluetooth keyboard
how much is it Wireless
can you send pic it's $20 yes it's
wireless does it work with phone tablets
and computers the pics are in the item
gallery what is the gray one the same
keyboard folded do you have to use the
keyboard can you use it as a speaker
it's just a keyboard never mind I'm
looking for a Bluetooth speaker do you
want this bowl created by granny
he won his bowl granny added you granny
change this group's icon to the bowl
Gregory left you're having that bowl
whether you want it or not
sounds like more of a demand for you to
take this bowl it's so funny i I never
thought of that
that's brilliant you could do that to
your friends name something that pisses
you the eff off
grandma is not amused people like you
that can't express themselves without
bad language that's right
I would never swear on my watch grandma
six-year-old co-worker has been texting
me every day for over a year
good morning good morning good morning
that's kind of cute no I don't want any
wholesome posts in these get out of here
aunt gave birth yesterday and my grandpa
was very excited grandpa okay okay okay
I mean there's really nothing you can't
get more excited than okay everyone
knows that's the pinnacle of expression
I wish I wish someone loved me as much
as this horse loves broccoli what what
Lowell that's a bear and a cantaloupe
but okay wolf and watermelon wolf and
watermelon does everyone see it
differently what do you see I see wolf
and watermelon it's this it's this about
a dress are they talking about the dress
that looked like it was what was it like
purple or yellow
this must technically count my aunt just
took a screenshot I mean I guess I guess
it worked it looks like it did a woman
died and her four children were injured
after a crash in the valley Sharon
by absolute 7:00 Sharon god damn see
this is why I love old people they have
absolutely no chill whatsoever this
seems a tad inappropriate
sorry don't know how to remove
yet still learning I love that you just
have an excuse for just everything as
well sorry still learning cuz I'm oh my
next apologies is gonna be still
learning that's what the are okay that
was it for old people Facebook wasn't
that a good time smash like check out
our Glee Christmas sweater dot-com /pt
PI and check out represent a concise
pewdiepie because of course you want to
look this good you want to become people
Christmas this is what you got okay
goodbye